I was explaining as you'll understand in
some of my previous lectures that I'm a
really terrible coach it's true it's
true you're laughing but it's true I
make mistakes all the time that's right
that's why I'm only a grand mass yeah
but I became world champion - I was
world champion under-21 yeah
but I make mistakes all the time in
chess and one of the things that we
understand
hi welcome hi see you brother
it's cool that's all right then okay
do you think I could trick you and make
you think 15 moves ahead okay I'm going
to trick you I'm going to trick you
okay I'm tricky I know isn't that
amazing I told you I'm not very good I
just
you can't play without that is so true
but I'm gonna cheat I told you I'm a
lousy coach that's right can't play
chess without a king but I can do
anything I want because see I'm a
grandmaster they give you a grandmaster
title they say you can do anything you
want now check out this position I just
made it up there's no black King in the
position I can't do that that's right I
can't do that but I'm doing it I'm doing
so play along with me here
so you guys all know how pawns boot you
know how Kings move okay in this
position this pawn is what we call a
base on a base pawn why do we why do you
think we call that the base yes
well it's on its original square but
that's not why we call it the base pawn
yes sir right that's it Wow oh that's a
that's the perfect answer this pawn is
called the base pawn because you see
this chain of ponds it's the last pawn
in the chain of ponds it's the base pond
it's at the very bottom of the chain of
ponds is this the base pond
how many think it is how many think it's
not okay
it is the base pond but why why did you
think why did you think it wasn't why
did you think it wasn't yeah these guys
good
okay well in fact there are two base
ponds the bay spawn in this case is the
one at the end of the chain right this
guy protects this guy this guy protects
this guy this guy protects this guy but
this guy is also a base pawn because it
protects these two guys okay but this is
a base pot now what we discover when we
play chess and we've become really
really experienced we discover it would
be really good to capture the base pawn
why yes no why would we like to write if
we could capture this base pawn then we
could capture this guy then this guy
this guy this guy so the base pawn is
like our foundation that's our crucial
pawn that protects everything now in
this position White's King is going to
have to capture this base pawn okay now
this is where I told you I'm a terrible
coach right so I don't want you to tell
me I don't want you to tell me how
you're going to do it I want you guys
mentally not to move the pieces but to
count in your mind how many moves it
would take you to capture the base part
think about it how many moves think
about it
how many moves would it take I'm gonna
call on you soon so be careful make sure
you've got to be a hundred percent right
100% how many think it will take you
three moves raise your hands three moves
more how many think it would take five
how many 6 how many 10 how many have the
right number
okay I'm gonna call on the gentleman in
red yes to tell me how many moves
how many 19 how many 18
how many yes seven how many
to capture the pawn 14 from ujin
how many 13 okay
you guys are going to count with me
right now but what are we counting we're
gonna count White's moves with this King
right now how on earth is White's King
which is way down here in the corner
ever ever gonna get to the g7 pond yes
okay come with me how many would like to
make this move okay
how many would like to make this move
Wow
okay so count with me 1 and now no I
made a mistake
hold on what was it 1 2 3 4 5 6
no okay how many raise your hands how
many would like to go here how many
would like to go here ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 now
what we're square this square or this
square how many would like to go to this
square ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
13 News we started here how is our
Poisson well there's no um Poisson
there's no um Poisson so you guys if you
if you calculated if you counted in your
minds you could think 13 moves ahead
it's not 13 - how did you get to how the
King had to go I know I'm only asking
how many moves does it take for the
White King the White King blacks didn't
move in all of this all I did was move
the White King how many moves did it
take the White King to win the bass pawn
you did what ah you did it the longer
now remember shall we try again you guys
how many like this is your opening move
that was that led to 13 but you guys
criticized me what was wrong with this
move is it still 13 if I move king G -
no okay it'd be 14 why why
okay let's try that again
okay how many moves does it take the
White King to reach the square - how
many moves does it take the White King
to reach this square if I do hear is it
the same thing yeah okay this this is
the way we start this is the way in
chess we start to think we start to
think we plan we plan ahead we have to
look ahead in this position we have a
plan our plan was to win the base pawn
right then you have to put your plan
into effect
now I've cheated because I didn't put a
black King on the board let's imagine
there was a black King on the board and
this black King if we moved our King all
the way up the board would stop us so
we're going to put the black King look
no hate that in a situation now how many
think the black king can stop the White
King from going after this pawn can the
black King stop the white king or is the
black King helpless to stop do you think
it can stop it
how many think the black King is
helpless it can't stop it okay now let's
see if that's true
first of all these are we call these
passed pawns right right so the black
King has to stop these pawns from
promoting to a queen because you all
know how to make checkmate with a king
and queen right and even to Queen that's
right so all of those who think the
black King can stop the white king keep
your hands up for a second
okay so you guys are going to tell us
how it's possible okay I'm gonna go King
here those people who think the black
King yes what would you do
okay I'm gonna go King here
and now yes d6 okay I'm gonna go here
I've got a queen you got to go back with
your king yeah he's gonna go back with
this King I'm gonna go here
goody yeah King to be seven I'm gonna go
here Oh
and now what are you gonna do with your
king
yes correct
but now how do you think the black king
is going to stop the white king king to
be seven king to d1 you got a you got to
stop me from making Queen a correct and
I'm coming over you see so the black
King can't stop the white king the black
king is helpless to stop me from going
after the base pawn
yes mmm
yeah he would take it here 'take it
that's a pity that's a pity okay this
little exercise and I could do a whole
lot of them I mean there are really a
lot of books about planning and chess
this little exercise is a way of helping
you understand how to plant one of the
most important things you can do as a
chess player is to have a goal your goal
in this case was to win the base pawn
and to make a plan how to make it happen
sometimes it takes 13 moves and longer
but if you have a goal you have a plan
that's what you need to become a
stronger chess player now I bet you guys
haven't heard of this but maybe you have
maybe you guys are a lot better than I
think have you you wanted the best
combinations how many of you know what a
combination is tactics and combinations
okay how many of you have heard of the
break through combination you've heard
of the break through combination what's
the break through
okay that's an interesting idea how many
else know about a breakthrough yes young
men well that sounds like a jumping over
the gate like you you jumped over the
fence well a breakthrough is kind of
like what you've suggested that there's
a fence but you break down the fence
okay one of the trickiest combinations
in the end game and the end game is the
breakthrough you guys like to see it I
couldn't believe it when it was first
shown to me now you guys are much much
stronger than me because guess what I
wasn't
I started playing chess at 12 so
everybody in this room all you guys are
much much much better than me as a
twelve-year-old because you know how to
play chess and I didn't so all you guys
should become better than me
wow what a concept is that sorry exactly
that's exactly right you should all turn
into national champions
well world champions I became a world
champion do you think you you guys think
you can do that too
why not okay now this time I'm not
cheating right because there's a black
black cane on the board okay now this is
pretty weird right this is this is
pretty weird okay how many people
realize that the Kings are in opposition
okay that's pretty good you guys you
guys are pretty good my goodness okay
now how many of you
I'm gonna try to trick you so pay
attention this is gonna be tough
how many you think white is winning
right is winning white is winning it's
white to move white it's White's move
how many of you think blacks winning
that's pretty good
how many of you think it's a tie that's
pretty good
okay so the people who think that black
is winning
what should black move be give me a move
for black what's the black what's a good
move for black no oh pardon me it's
white to move it's right to move white
to move okay
those people think White's winning raise
your hand okay what should white play
okay and if I play King to c3 the idea
for white is maybe he would try to go
and capture these pawns right so black
moves his King into opposition now what
should white do okay and then the same
thing from blacks point of view black
plays King to d5 pawn to f6 and let's
say black takes the pond
then we take the pawn back and then
black place here and black what sorry
that the king would come here and black
would be winning right black wins okay
so we just saw an example of black
winning the game after the move King to
c3 so now once again I asked the class
how many think black is winning I'm a
dirty trickster I'm telling you I'm
warning you and how many think White's
winning how what would you do if you
were white okay check this out white
played the move g6 whoa
how many think that's a good move okay
how many think black is still winning
two three okay what should black play
what he should take the pawn right
okay let me play black I'm going to take
the pong so I'm upon up and now what do
you do okay how this way or this way
okay now after F takes G six I'll play H
6
okay now what are you guys gonna you
guys got white what are you gonna do are
you gonna go king c3 what else can you
do you can't do anything but move your
king your pawns are stuck where would
you like to move your king if not C and
a half well if you go king - C - let's
say black goes King here huh what is
blacks going to do is black going to go
after the base Bond
what's the base pond
h5 so black is gonna go here here here
here cake and then he's going to take
that one too
and he's gonna be two phones up and he's
gonna win the game so black wins again
yay
well that's what we're going to try to
find out so the score what's the score
two to nothing two to nothing white to
play and it's been two to nothing
so are we convinced that black is
winning no okay tie that timeout
the young gentleman he said that he
would like to play the move g6 and this
is a very interesting move now last time
F takes I played the move F takes G six
and you guys captured the pawn
I played h6 and black was winning
okay how about how many of you would
like to play this move yes and then what
would you then what would you do after
this move take it again
but then isn't isn't isn't blacks king
clothes and won't blacks King come over
and just capture the pawn no the pawn is
blocked so black is going to win this
pawn maybe he won't win the game maybe
he will but blacks better right blacks
better yes sir well he would but black
in this position white might be able to
draw there's no question about that but
there's only one potential winner right
only black could win this position
because only black has a pawn so this
didn't work out very well for white what
at all yes we'll find out later that now
I want you guys to give this some
serious thought because white has a
brilliant move a brilliant move and I
want to see if you guys can find it
this move is winning for white
huh yeah baby it's a win for white now I
want you guys to tell me after I play
this move what possibilities give me all
of whites possibilities what are
possible moves for white yes sir how
many of you like that move isn't that
brilliant
why okay okay
what could black do take the pawn now
what can white do in the red the
gentleman in the red White's pawn is
going to promote to Queen and he's going
to win you don't have anything that the
King is too far away to stop the pawn
okay but now but now you guys haven't
got it all yet this is just the start
okay put on your thinking caps this is
very important
I mean this is for the championship
imagine this is for ya
imagine this is for the national
championship
and you're white and you're facing the
international Grandmaster and you have a
winning move and you played this move
and you played the winning move and your
coach is nervous and the Grandmaster
that's me just to remind you the
Grandmaster captures like this now think
about it think about it
give it some thought what on earth can
black play
pardon me what on earth can white play
what could white play okay
is this the right move the national
championship just a second
what's the right move the lady in white
yes you young lady you could capture the
pawn yes no the gentleman in the blue
and the way back yes how many of you
like that move
what if black captures the pawn now what
your two pawns down just second your two
pawns down gentleman in the green you
yes Wow powerful move right do you see
why there's no stopping the fun and for
example let's play it out I'll play
black will you guys make a queen now
okay okay let's say I go here you guys
play a whoops you guys play against me
now I'm gonna play black okay are you
ready young man what would you do how
many of you like to move the Queen to e5
check jack
I'd better go back Queen takes pawn okay
now I'm playing black I'm playing
against a whole class you guys are a
queen ahead so I've got to figure out a
draw do you want to draw come on
okay what am i play f5 young lady what
would you do this one how many would
like to move the Queen to g5 then why
would you move the Queen to g5 young
young men that is true but why the he's
right no he is right about that but why
did white move his Queen here yes sir
okay what pawn is the white queen trying
to capture young lady in the red all the
way in the back of the class yes what
pawn is the white queen trying to
capture correct she is absolutely right
let's say I play King here she says that
she wants to take this pawn on g6 and
what kind of a pawn is it
a base pot and now that the base pond
has been captured so I'm gonna play here
now it's your turn
you guys still want to draw okay what
are you going to do
generally a young lady in the white to
which square which square this is the
fifth-ranked h5 is a good move because
this move pins the pond but I was
thinking that you're going to need to
use your and you need to bring your king
close to to this pond okay so give me
another suggestion young lady okay King
to c3 this was the move I liked the best
let's say I play King here young man
what would you do
King to c4 okay let's say I move my King
here young man yes yes you ready
who else has a good idea gentleman King
to d3 I like this move very much I think
this move is very good now what if I
move my King here
young men what do you think you would do
if you had the white pieces this is a
national championship Bravo
right there is e - e - okay now I'm in
trouble I know it okay I still have one
hope I'll move my king here now what
will you guys do young men check Queen
to e6 check you're attacking my King
you're attacking my pawn
I have only one square to protect it
King f4 yes what's your move are you
thinking young man what's your move
Queen to c4 okay Queen the c4 check now
let's say I go King here now remember
you guys still gotta beat me I'm a
grandmaster I got a pawn you guys want
to draw boy young man in the blue what
do you think you should do oh that
that's a now I'm not gonna call on you
again that move is too good now hold on
I got a think I'm in trouble here I know
I just know if I move my pawn you guys
are going to take it right okay
so I'll go King here are you sure
what's your move young man f4 is a good
square but what's going there the king
or the queen it's his choice what king
okay
Wow I I don't see how I don't see how
I'm gonna save the pawn do you I don't
so I'm gonna play here take a bond
okay we got take the pawn now you guys
are going to show me I asked you at the
start of the class if you guys could win
king and queen versus King and now it's
the test this is it
this is the big test can you do it how
many of you think you can do it pretty
good okay I'm going to play King here
take a look be careful this is for the
championship now gentlemen in the blue
what do you think you would do if you
had white move the Queen to e4 is is
everybody happy with this move
timeout who thinks the Queen should move
here okay who thinks the Queen should
move here why not
okay timeout I've got to try to guess
what you guys want to do the suggestion
was Queen to e4 check this is the this
was the move that was suggested who
thinks they have a better move young man
in the blue what is the better move King
to g4 how many people like that move you
guys are gonna need to use your King one
day how many of you would like to move
the King to e5 I'm I'm not hearing a lot
of unanimous praise Queen to D how many
of you like to go Queen to d5 okay a lot
of agreement
so I we're gonna suggest to you guys a
move is that a fair I can be the arbiter
so keep in mind that I'm trying to make
a draw so I'm going to suggest you guys
play here exactly I'm trying to draw but
that was the worst suggestion ever
okay because Queenie forecheck was
suggested before you guys are gonna have
to tough it out I'll play King here
young man Queen you guys just were there
guess what I'll go right back
hahaha okay but okay what are you guys
gonna do instead gentleman in the blue
because you're so good you can't move
the King White King can't go to e4 you
me maybe King to e5 okay King to e5
I'm gonna go King f3 your turn Queen
daddy for good move very good move I'm
gonna go King to g3 young lady in the
white okay Queen to d3 check I'm going
to play King to g2 okay who's gonna play
White's next move this is a crucial move
young man championships on your
shoulders yes
that was an excellent move oh that was
an excellent move I'm playing King to h2
and gentleman in the red
that's an excellent move what was wrong
with that bow where can my King go I
have to go here you sure yeah but keep
going look okay young man in the orange
moving this square or this square you
but you want to go around my king you
want to use your king teeth - that's
true
this is this is an idea but it's not the
best move in the position King to f4 now
I have nothing else to do King h2 okay
how many of you before I call how many
of you think you can checkmate in five
moves or raise your hands five moves how
many think you can check Maidan for
nobody thinks you could check good that
is what how many can checkmate in two
moves how would you play for white what
would you do which move would you make
queen g4 but that would that be check
made in to young man the suggestion was
Queen to g4 and Queen to g3 and both of
those Queen moves are good but is not
the best you got a checkmate in two
that's the exercise young man that's
brilliant and now young man checkmate in
one move
checkmate in one move show me how you
could checkmate in one move
it's awesome in the blue checkmate
congratulations okay what did we learn
in this class what did we learn in this
class these are the things I want to
remind you I want to remind you what is
the base pawn right how to plan think of
a plan and then execute your plan and
and today you learned the break through
the where you push that pawn and then
you push the other pawn or you push the
other part and your pawn went through to
a queen and you and you learned that I
was a lousy coach yeah now what is
happening here at the club is every
Sundays we have these classes at 1:00 to
2:00 there are also during the weekdays
intermediate classes okay
classes for players who are getting
stronger and stronger there's an entire
schedule